hi i'm navy grandson of team see it
by google slickness and in the episode of
today should bytes
Let's see how the navigation tags in the
your android app quite
navigation are a widely used feature
since the early versions of android
used very well by the
applications are generally available and
then with the action bar the form of
to set up the inauguration date was a
his appearance was also slightly altered.
reused to integrate better know
a pub
if you do not know is to hit what?
learn how to implement your
application has a link in the video that
Can you see an episode we did?
discussions on use of the action
neighborhood
we have some types of action on va
which has different deployments and uses
different
in the case here first it is the slaves
or tevez you can use anchored to
also move to the other of
side is to make the movement of
Sweetie, you run your finger across the board.
the example image in the case here is of the
google places and can change
categories available only
making a move with the finger exchanging
from one page to another that facilitates
very much the skill and experience of the
user
then the fixed telephones that are the most
used it is worth remembering that
there must be a smaller number of tags
because you do not follow too much
interface
But it stays and integrates well with the
use the action bar after we have the
tags stacked in the case when you
has for example I was here on the screen is
where I have vertically the tags the part
from below and horizontally the teles will
for the top are on the side logo
the only one of your application this way
making better use of screen space without
that you care a lot about it in the
code can assemble the layout you will have
some special care that may
implement navigation tags
the first thing your layout has to contain
a group virus where it will be
fragments with content will be associated
to this tag and remember that you set edp
civil group so you can in your
code identify easy which one did you see this
replaces content in the correct form
Besides that
if you are going to use the entire screen to
view the content until you
create a new group
you can use android account r
points as there were
ruth and put all the content straight there
and how the implement then tog
navigation or a peek in the
people can make their implementation
the first thing is a class that
implement interface action a boat
had list, which is the class responsible
for receiving the events is by cauby tech
of his thesis the user clicks on a
technique that molds until then has to
call this class that will change the
content or upgrade and in addition to
every time you want to create you
will create an instance of action bar
tab and set the table list that
You implemented what we talked about in a
previous step calling method 7
enable
and finally after you create a tag
added list you add tab action
neighborhood through the method is tagged as
A little glance now then how to make the
implementation of this in the code
even we have here the android manifest
I would like to remind you if as already
was said to have to implement that
so I put the theme here
as it fears point is compact light but if
Can you understand what time you are?
want to
to be able to implement
to begin here then by the feminist
the class that implements interface action
accountant who will take care of
codecs when the user clicks matter
go to another
the consultant receives an asset of
assets that have tags a tag to
to identify each tebe every weak is
displayed and finally the class fragments that
is displayed with the content
in the first half is seeing here that is
of kardec or a select park of or
when a selected board
People here try to get through the
probably less support that talking
only by the tag you pass the constructor
if it is null or has not yet been
displayed was not created I wanted a
new instance and replays in content
that it is displayed
if it had already been created, I already
I am simply of the attic or
resumes displaying the content on the web but
when you have a method yesterday
a select because if a table is
selected, the other has to be
then everyone should always
you click on a strip a selection and
puts another
in this case I check if it is null
panther landino tip and then if he does not
whether it was not null and simply
tete or remove it from the
screen display
but how am I going to use this guy with
the panamera tivit tags I'll then have
here I'm going to get a boat and remembering
integrated with edson bar and you're 19
Complaining 79 Geisha Trade Template
mold for action one bar point
navigation template indicating
However, all tags with the
browsing your app
after that I create each TV in case
has an artist tag and a tag
album and set list with seven stabilizes
It's because it was clear that you just showed
what you used and then with that
to finish sent the ad that goes
show within the appropriate content
let's take a look then how
this result of this implementation
here I have here then our
content with two tevez
the artist uses some and has collected click
here you see that it replaced content
from one tag to another and so you can
use the blatant a way well
interesting in the next episodes
Let's show you how you can improve.
even more your experience the annexes
a bar so you already know how isaac
Chumbar and now the new Tevez Geishas
until the next staff